Tom Cruise every time I'm here I sound
like your mother because you do the
stunts and I worry for you I were I just
think stop now luck running out you know
there's only so many times you do these
crazy things like the last Mission
Impossible you learned how to hold your
breath underwater tell the people how
long this is incredible how long can you
hold your breath for underwater six and
a half minutes good right those takes
underwater because it took from the time
you get rid of the regulator get rid of
the bubbles get on the side and we
wanted to do it in one shot so they were
very very long shot so these takes took
you know they'd have to hold it
consistently you know safely up to four
minutes almost for every take what's the
point of why bother but we're committed
everyone was there the camera was set up
that just like what am I gonna say it
was too late to say no how is that
possible decent sort can a breathing do
they do you know no it's just that you
have these free divers that came in and
trained me how to do it and it's it's
it's not pleasant
it's really keeps you panicked you get
to not leave no actually you you get to
the moment where you train your your
your system to I'm now under I'm
controlling the breath so I've got a low
heart rate anyway and I would very low
heart rate which means my body's not
using as much oxygen but also we did
stuff to bring the heart rate down lower
in certain breathing exercises and I
trained for a long time to the point
when I finish the sequence there'd be
times I'd be sitting there talking and
meetings and I wouldn't breathe I
realize I am not breathing and I had to
turn my auto anomic system back on to
breathing it that's bad yeah
a little I I did that so I've done with
that but actually judo oh no you know
now stop running no sobbing get a young
Brooke any young Pope you knew hold your
breath about 40 seconds here time it was
all six half minutes but it was a long
time yeah it's no sixteen off middle did
you train for it so you know you know I
get agony
I mean it's pain I didn't actually
because it's not it what it really isn't
that long in the script he's he's he's
had this trauma I want to give anything
away he give him a little peasant prayer
and he decided he wasn't get away from
everyone so he's in the bottom of his
palatial swimming pool so that the shot
starts on the back of men are we had to
time the length of the prayer we overton
over a minute let's say that yeah and it
comes around and we had to time you said
it comes around and are you saying the
thing that takes the longest he's
watching down there you wait for the
bubbles to clear yes and they're ready
and any here because they've got
microphones into you did you start to
feel you do a little change yes to come
you could feel these that's what's about
the planning cuz I would I was just
trying to count it or recite the prayer
but then I worried that the prayer would
start changing speed so I start counting
and then I knew every time I got to like
70 I was always kind of thinking okay
they hope they're there soon cuz then I
had to trust that they were in front of
me for when I open my eyes do this and
then I go up so Wow let it was no six
and a half minutes so you know that pain
I mean I had to train just feel stuff I
do the first time I did it was like yeah
learning that kind of stuff is that is
honestly I think ya know six nice
minutes no uh but it is it's a girl you
know you learn to do these weird things
and wonderful things like so many useful
thing to know how to do I mean
say you're out with you know when you
get thrown out of the boat and you're
down there now you know how to hold your
breath I could stay alive for an extra
six minutes you got the wrong yeah he
does the last one who died want to go
yeah
Victor wave them all and goodbye they
all hate you as they die yeah it's
useful if I
[Music]